The Joe Rogan experience, dude, I've bombed a lot. I just.
I believe that I don't, I talked to Joe,
I had George Lopez on my podcast two days ago and he was talking about bombing,
but you're a Fred Rogie. Yeah, you're a Joe Grogan. He's he's George Lopez.
What the? How do you guys don't bomb? You have to.
Come up with new material and if you're going to come up with new material,
some of them are going to be duds. That's just how it is. Yeah.
And also you have to take chances if you want to expand, like comedy is a,
there's a, there's a bunch of things going on, right?
There's you relating to the audience, there's a them liking you.
There's these concepts. You're trying to flesh out the,
and especially in a workout room, like the comedy store, like you,
you have to take chances. There's no way around it.
And sometimes those chances fall flat on their face.
But the good thing is those through those painful failures,
those are like the biggest springboards to improvement and growth.
Like every time I've ever had a bad set,
my next set has been amazing because you just feel the sting and you prepare
better. And also, like,
I think my past bombings have prepared me to not bomb again because of the
fact that I know what it feels like to suck.
So I always explain it that it's like something what's bombing.
Like it's like sucking a thousand in front of your mother,
except there's probably someone out there that likes sucking a thousand father
and mother. No one likes bombing. You know, there's probably some guy,
I was just really into humiliation,
but I don't think there is just no one out there is in the bombing.
Oh man. I just, yeah, but because it's like, Oh, well, listen, listen, well,
what am I will bet you that no one is bombed harder than me.
Well, that's not possible. [inaudible] bro.
How's it possible that by the, we,
your trustee savant next to us young, Jamie will pull up.
Did you just stand up? We,
he can pull up me bombing in front of a billion
people. What did you do? The Academy awards. Ooh, you hosted it.
Well, here's the thing. So I talk about bombing.
My bigger than your Dick about um,
I'm 24, 24 years old.
I'm doing my movies.
The Academy awards asked me to do a
big opening number for them. I'm like, Holy. This is it.
This is a man will get pulled off of YouTube. Yeah. God.
See some look like I'll play it for us.
So when we were free to play before and I go, what context, what context.
Stop.
Or I'll bomb again? I'll bomb right now again. So they say to me,
they go, we want you to do, and I'm like throw this years as high honor,
86 high hot high honor, California. Sure.
And I should have liked thought
it through. Cause the idea didn't sound great to me,
but it's the Academy awards, you know, they know better than I do.
It's their show.
And the idea is it's going to be an homage to old time Hollywood.
And one of the earliest stars in Hollywood was, um, snow white,
the animated figure. So we're going to have a LA girl,
obviously playing snow white.
And we're going to do a duet because it's a big opening musical number of the
Oscars always used to open with musical numbers before there were monologues.
Really? Yeah. Oh yeah. Yes. This ended, it
ended it. Um, so, uh, I'm like,
okay. I mean it's okay. I mean, it's not like great. Okay.
And anyway, um,
Marvin Hamlisch is gonna write it Marvin Hamlisch I'm like nine old Marvin
Hamlisch as he wrote the staying down and, and then it,
while Scott Joplin wrote the staying,
but Marvin Hamlisch won the Academy award for that he's double Aw,
squeeze a genius. And you know,
I'm not going to tell Marvin Hamlisch should I think that the lyrics are cheesy,
but could do that. So when they get Ike and Tina Turner's proud Mary
and change the lyrics to did a lot of work for, well,
it is ni Ooh. Oh yeah, yeah. Oh no.
I'm saying it's about.
Yes. And we're going to pause for the people at home. If you need to,
if you need to watch this YouTube, um, Jamie, what is it? What does it mean?
It's on the Hollywood reporters website. I don't know why it's there.
It probably,
what is the title of the actual video blow bombs like that disastrous open?
I don't know.
Rob Lowe and snow wides disastrous Oscar opening,
February 20th, 2007.
Actually the title for the people. It literally says disastrous. Okay.
Folks at home, Google this, watch it.
And then we're going to pick this up after Robin. I've watched this.
Yes. Is it Lily Tomlin at the end? Now that's a, that's a truncated version.
Give you much of it, but, but can I tell you something where, but I,
I, that was the year that, um, Barry Levinson.
I could tell just from the first bar, is that going to be bad? Yeah.
When you were saying, did you take same lessons?
Nah, the whole thing. What's that sound like? It's 11 minutes long.
It's sheer terror on YouTube. If you want to look.
Have 11 minutes that ruined Hollywood producer, Alan Carr's career forever.
Hold on. We'll be right back.
He's like, wait, hang on, hang on folks. I need, I need to see this.
First of all, I get it. I get it. Okay. I look out in the middle of it.
I look at it in the middle of the audience.
And I see Barry Levinson. So he's at this, on this Oscars.
He's about to win literally 11 Academy awards as an actor.
There's no one you would want impress more than Barry Levinson.
It's the year of rain man.
And I look out Joe in the middle of this and I see his face. I'm not kidding.
And he's, this is what he literally was going. [inaudible] what the
you see him actually make? I see him mouth, the words, what the.
And, and so I talk about bombing and I'm like, but you know,
we have to have our, our, our actors denial.
Like we can't get through a career without a healthy dose of denial.
So I'm like, you know what, Barry Levinson, what does he know anyway, that guy.
And I go backstage and it's in the green room and it's early because
it's early in the show.
And there's an older lady in the corner with like flaming red hair.
And I'm kind of looking at her and she sees me. She goes young, man.
I didn't know you as such a good singer. Come sit down. And it was Lucille ball.
And I went over and we sat down and she held my hand and we watched the
Oscars together. And you know what?
It made it all made it all almost worthwhile almost.
Here's why that's not as bad as bombing doing standup. How is that?
Not as bad as bad because even though a billion people watched it a,
you didn't write it. And B you knew where you were going.
You could just sing the stupid song and get it over with. It's terrible.
It's bombing. It's bad. But when you're bombing doing stand-up,
you are the writer. You are the creator.
You are the performer, put it together, you edited it,
you prepared it. You got it ready. And then you're just up there eating.
And people are angry at you. They're angry. They're angry because they.
Oh, they were angry. Oh, I'm sure they were angry.
Here's the other thing they did that they never occurred to the Academy to
maybe, maybe that they needed to license the likeness of snow white.
Oh yeah. Oh no. Oh yeah.
And, and you know how Disney is about likenesses? Oh, they're so easy going.
The other. So they're so generous, so.
Generous so that see, I would've thought I would've got,
I think I would've gotten away with it a little bit in terms of history,
had there not been massive lawsuits the next day? Oh,
over the likeness thing,
which may then people thought about it and people went back and went,
wait a minute. That sucked way worse than I thought it did.
What was the next thing you did after that?
I think let's see. Would it have been?
I feel like it might've been bad influence with Curt,
with James Spader and crew one of my favorites.
That's a great movie. I love that. That's a good way to bounce back.
That was a good one. Let's look at the bright side. Yeah.
No, listen. And it is a.
Did you consider saying no, no, no.
I ate people pleasing Midwesterner at
24 does not say no to the Academy of motion, picture arts and sciences.
They don't. And every year, every year I am treated to the honor,
the high honor of being on the list of most embarrassing Oscar moments every
year. And, and, and my thing is this is I go, Hey, wait guys,
you couldn't figure out how to announce the best picture two
years ago. And I'm the problem still?
Oh.
Well it wasn't your fault. I mean, no one would have saved that. No one, no one,
not in a human being could have jumped up there and sang that.
And had it made any sense, maybe Jim Carey, maybe yes. Maybe Jamaica,
Jim Carrey could have done it,
but he would have gone full ACE Ventura over the top and people would have
been just laughing hysterically and how crazy.
It's, it's one of my great, um, career,
low light slash highlights. I, it actually,
it actually kind of makes me laugh with, with, with the, uh,
onset of perspective and history.
That's the beautiful thing about failures.
They eventually become funny and they can, yes.
Back at them. It only took 30 years. That's great.